that is incredible 85 fps 100 gpu usage
this is awesome is the new m1 ultra max
studio that i have right here a beast at
gaming well we are going to answer that
question in this video because i'm about
to play a bunch of games in fact 10 of
them including grand theft auto 5 the
witcher 3 world of warcraft native cs go
and a bunch of other games to figure out
if you can finally get really good
gaming performance despite using other
apps like crossover 20 to play actual
windows games on this machine well we
are going to answer that question and by
the way you can see i'm wearing our m1
ultra design t-shirt right now and if
you want to support us you can find that
in the merch shelf below and definitely
use the code m1 ultra for 20 off any of
our merch so without further ado let's
get right into the gaming and we're
jumping straight to grand theft auto 5
this is by far the most popular game in
our previous video so let's jump in but
to play that on mac os you need
something called crossover 21 as you can
see right here we have the crossover
trial so if you download it you get two
weeks free to try it out but if you want
to buy it and play gta 5 or any of the
other games all the time you can use the
code max tech 25 for 25
off so definitely do that so here we are
in the gta 5 settings and the first
thing i'm gonna do is match up the
settings to the same ones that i played
on the macbook pros so that we could
actually compare the scores so as you
can see i've set it to 1920 by 1080. so
right off the bat all these cut scenes
are working just fine
sitting at 76 fps this is definitely
improved compared to how the uh m1 max
macbook pro played now what's
interesting is for some reason the gpu
says only 43 usage you can see that
right there 40 45 so it's uh literally
limiting it even though i don't have
vsync on looks like i'm getting around
40
fps here
33 what it is a little bit glitchy here
35 it's definitely not what i wanted to
see to be honest all right check this
out if you look at the gpu usage
only 25 gpu usage what is going on well
so far i mean we can tell that
something's going wrong with the m1
ultra like we're getting performance
that's on par or like slightly worse
than what we saw with the m1 max now
moving on to the next game let's
actually play something that is
optimized for metal and for apple
silicon and that is of course world of
warcraft we should be getting some
insane fps in that game all right here
we are in world of warcraft let's go
ahead and get into
the graphics settings as you can see we
have full screen windowed and i'm going
to match the settings that i played on
the macbook pro so you can see i have
all this stuff turned up to high
10 out of 10 detail and the resolution
is the closest i can get it
to
the macbook pro that i played with 180
fps right now guys so this is the kind
of performance you should be seeing with
the m1 ultra seeing as it's actually
properly optimized so with that done i'm
going to call this around an average of
165 to 170 fps at these settings and
compared to the macbook pros you
definitely see a nice difference with
the ammon ultra so this is how it should
be performing with basically an
optimized game unlike using crossover to
play grand theft auto 5. and just to
show you guys i'm just gonna go all out
on the resolution just match up what i
have right here 5120 by 2880 5k
resolution with everything maxed out and
look at that 122 fps 115
playing at 5k
everything maxed out
that is incredible and once again let me
mention that this is the 64 core gpu
version of the m1 ultra with 128
gigs of memory that's totally overkill
for gaming like you'd be fine with the
64 no problem at all and now with that
said let's move on to the next game that
is eve online which is supposed to be
optimized for mac os and i have not
played this on the macbook pro i'm just
gonna test it out and see look at that
that's beautiful this is actually like
very smooth looks like i'm running at 4k
res texture quality is on medium right
now a lot of this stuff is actually at
high so it looks like we're running out
solid
60 fps it dips down to 59 sometimes and
i don't think there's vertical sync here
as far as i can tell so i'm just gonna
turn up the graphics let's do 5k okay 5k
still at 60fps eve online no problems
okay let's go to
high texture quality literally 5k res no
issues 60fps solid like we're rendering
all this stuff no problems at all so
this is definitely a metal
optimized game definitely let me
actually switch to uh windowed mode okay
so windowed mode 79 usage so it still
has a little bit more headroom gpu is
using 56 watts oh look at that it just
unlocked
in windowed mode we're getting 80 that
is incredible 85 fps 100 gpu usage
this is awesome incredibly optimized now
moving on to the next game let's play
some cs go all right here we are and i
do want to mention guys that this is
through rosetta so this is being
translated this is not actually
optimized natively for apple silicon
it's just like an x86 based mac game
translated over and now with that said i
want to match up these settings to what
i played on the macbook pro so let's go
ahead and set this down
to
1080p is what i played at set these down
to medium which is what i had before
media media medium and arms race for
sure i'm playing that all right so i
actually have to go into full screen
mode but you can see we're using up to
87 90 of the gpu so it's actually really
good look at that we're over a hundred
right now oh i just saw like 230 what
let me switch over oh
into a full screen mode actually this
should make it a little bit easier to
see there you go wow over a hundred the
entire time i'm not feeling any
glitchiness at all like you could easily
hook up a 144 hertz
display
gaming display and just get some nice
fps oh i actually saw 70 right there so
comparing that to the macbook pros i
think the lowest that i saw on the 32
core m1 max is actually 62 and the
lowest i saw here was actually 78 but on
the high side i actually saw well over
200 while actually playing so that is a
big improvement compared to
the macbook pros let's see what happens
when we go 5k this will be nuts let's
see oh i cannot see the fps counter at
all it's still over 100 at 5k resolution
the resolution doesn't matter are you
serious okay i saw it go down to 70
right there it's sitting at 90 100 oh
that is absolutely insane and now here
we are in dota 2 as you can see i have
the graphic settings set to the best
looking 2560 by 1440 for the resolution
let's go ahead and hit apply and let's
get into the game all righty
we just saw there look at that 150
perfectly smooth no issues i'm sure
you'd be able to just grab a 120 fps 144
fps monitor turn down the settings a
little bit
get perfect
performance so it's actually quite nice
now while this is performing better than
the m1 max in the macbook pro it is not
that big of a difference because before
i was getting around 98 to 117 fps but
now like oh wow look at that 170. it's
around 120
to around 150 fps
average and now i do want to test out
the resolution let's see if we could
just do 5k and look at that once again
it doesn't care 130 fps at 5k resolution
oh look at that now while i am in a
battle i am seeing
70s now i mean the m1 ultra is what you
want to get if you want to play it high
refresh rate or just crazy 5k resolution
fully maxed out no issues by the way
guys in all those games i have been
playing i have literally not heard the
fans
at all they are completely silent
they're running at idle right now 1300
rpm 51 degrees celsius on the cpu the
gpu is also 50.
everything's just so cool with that said
let's play a little bit of path of exile
let's see how much fps we can get
compared to the macbook pros now i'm
matching up the settings to what we had
on the macbook pros and let's just jump
into it and i do want to mention i'm
turning off dynamic resolution to make
sure we're fully maxing out right here
we are in path of exile and it looks
like it's stuck to a solid
60fps for some reason let me take a look
vsync is disabled so i don't know why
well here we are i mean it's playing
just fine no problems at all on path of
exile and this is actually what we
experienced with the m1 max so both of
those chips are just fine for this game
if you are interested in it all right
the next game we got is starcraft 2. all
right and here we are in the settings
we're setting it to 4k resolution
slightly higher than on the macbook pros
refresh rate default we're setting this
stuff up higher the shaders are on
medium because for some reason high was
glitchy in the past so i'm going to keep
it the same as it was on the macbook pro
ultra ultra ultra on all the stuff
extreme physics let's jump into it and
looking at the fps i mean that fps
counter is absolutely tiny looks like a
150 160 fps solid now as i'm walking out
i'm getting around 110 120 fps whoa you
did boy all right so look at that 70 70
fps during the battle interesting i
wonder why the m1 max actually seemed
like it was getting around 90 fps
during battle so i'm not sure what's
different here it should actually be
quite a bit better but let me try to up
the resolution 5k see if there's
anything different and it's still
sitting at the same
70. no difference with going max out 5k
resolution so i mean that's one benefit
it seems like the m1 ultra doesn't care
about resolution much so all right and
now let's play some minecraft now there
is a way that you could play the native
apostle conversion with a hack it's the
mc multi i think it's called but this is
just the regular rosetta version we're
gonna see if you just play this version
and still get good fps so i'm gonna set
the settings to as close as i did on the
macbook pro and let's see what we get
okay here we are and as you can see
we're getting around 92 but i am getting
some glitchiness like it just dropped to
like 30. yeah i'm definitely not happy
with uh this performance i expected more
so it seems like if you want to get
crazy fps you're going to want to play
the apple silicon version because i
think it gets like like 300 fps what if
the rosetta translation limits it to
around the same amount of fps like no
matter how much graphics power you have
actually only go to
windowed mode so right there you see
we're at around 100 fps
but if you look at our gpu only 53 is
being used only 55 like that is weak cpu
is barely being used like this is
completely unoptimized with rosetta it's
we're sitting at around 100 115 fps
whereas the m1 max was sometimes hitting
a maximum of 130 which is interesting
and now the next game is the witcher 3
which is a windows game so i am using
crossover which is doing the emulation
and translation between the windows code
to macos metal code so let's go ahead
and test it out once again i'm going to
make sure i have the same settings so
around 1080p so let's go ahead try it
out here we go and hey i am actually
noticing a good difference between this
and the m1 max macbook pro wow look at
that 130 fps right now 150 fps i was not
expecting that especially since this is
literally crossover and it is definitely
nowhere near as glitchy
and stuttery as it was this is very
impressive let me remind you of what the
macbook pros got i think
we're sending out 45 to 50 fps on the m1
max macbook pro and we're literally
somehow i don't know how maybe some sort
of update we're now looking at 120 130
140 even 150 fps all right here we go i
found some guys
this will be the ultimate test okay yep
oh i'm getting some drop frames here and
it froze
what
everything was good until it froze what
in the world just happened as soon as i
attacked the guy it just freezes well
while everything was good we were
getting good fps and now let's move on
to league of legends this is another mac
os game that's running through rosetta
so also not apple silicon optimized all
right going into the graphics settings i
want to make sure it matches up gonna go
4k a little bit higher than i had before
let's just turn everything up
literally to the max
frame rate cap
uncapped all right currently sitting at
110
oh look at that 88 it actually dropped
down 88.92
interesting
oh that's not what i want to do
hey you're welcome guys that was because
of me
no
wow 64 it dropped to during this uh
battle and now it's up to 121 so now the
interesting thing is it seems like on
the m1 max macbook pro i don't think it
hit as low as 62 which is interesting it
was around
around 70 actually for the minimum so
compared to the m1 max it's not really
giving us a massive amount of
performance it's kind of being
held back which is super unfortunate now
with that said let's go ahead just max
it out 5k resolution 5k res and i'm
getting around the same fps 66 i just
saw a low of so it's like does it even
care now there was a theory by hitchnash
and his theory was that
it basically looks at your refresh rate
and if you need the performance it gives
it to you but if you don't you don't get
nothing now i want to play some fortnite
now this is not a game that i played
with those other macbook pros but i'm
curious to see how much performance we
can get and i think i'm just going to go
straight up and go all the way to 5k
resolution because
it seems like the system looks at your
resolution looks at the 60hz refresh
rate and no matter what even if you turn
v-sync off it clocks down the gpu to
save energy
which i don't know if apple's actually
doing this or not but it seems like they
are and it's extremely annoying and i
really really really wish
that it had uh in 144 hertz refresh rate
display but unfortunately i don't so
let's just max this out like crazy epic
everything turn off that v-sync motion
blur we don't need show fps on sitting
at 35 fps so
definitely not what you would want i'm
actually going to turn down the settings
a little bit we'll keep the resolution
the same let's just turn down some of
these settings okay now sitting at
around 40 turn down the graphics
settings or the resolution actually 4k
let's try that there we go so at 4k this
is feeling a lot more smooth sitting at
70 right now so 4k res over 60 like
almost all the time now let's see if you
wanted to play with a
144hz display let's just try 1440p in
case you have a 1440p 144 hertz and now
we're finally seeing over a hundred
check that out it does dip down to as
low as 80 i just saw right there but let
me get up
yeah
all right so as low as 80 right there i
just saw 70. so 110 fps oh look at that
nice let's go a little bit lower 1080p
honestly it didn't really go up by much
we're still sitting at around like a
hundred just over a hundred back to
1440p let's turn some of these settings
down to medium and it just doesn't care
look at that
it's still at like 90. well playing at
1440p right now i mean we have times
where we go down to 80 times we hit 120
but i'd say
still a pretty decent experience but
you're really not taking advantage of
that 64 core
m1 ultra i mean it's just it's not
really being utilized that well let me
try windowed okay window we're getting
over 100 fps and interestingly the gpu
says that it's being used 95
so rosetta is really killing the
performance of this game however fans
everything's still on idle very cool 50
degrees celsius it's obviously not being
pushed to the limits look at that 50 48
it's not being pushed to the limits at
all all right guys and with all that
said in all of those games played here
is my conclusion well first of all if
you know you're going to be playing
apple silicon optimized games like eve
online or world of warcraft then you're
definitely going to be taking advantage
of the m1 ultra chip and for some
rosetta games we also got really good
performance like in cs go where we got a
really solid 60 up to over 100 fps which
was very nice compared to the m1 max
which did have a little bit of
glitchiness but in almost every other
game with rosetta or crossover there
were just issues where it wasn't really
utilizing the gpu all the way like
sometimes we're getting 30 percent gpu
usage especially gta 5 using crossover
it was just not optimized and not really
using that gpu the 64 core so that was
actually very very disappointing so
my conclusion is that
you should not go higher than the m1 max
chip if you're going to be playing a lot
of different games that are not apple
silicon optimized it's just a waste
because in so many different games
the resolution didn't really matter we
went up to 5k and we sustained around
the same fps so it's almost like apple
is either intentionally limiting down
the performance or if there's something
with rosetta where rosetta has like this
hard limit where it just doesn't really
let you fully push the gpu which is so
disappointing
so with that said i think the m1 max is
a better chip for overall gaming unless
you're playing games like wow or eve
online where it can really take
advantage of it so once again if you
want to try out crossover use the coupon
code maxtech25
to get 25 off i'll leave the link down
in the description below and hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
click the circle about to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]